E aí
a falar de comida para mim alguma coisa
Sempre
prazerosa primeiro que eu gosto muito de
comer e porque eu gosto de cozinhar
segundo porque ao longo da carreira do
meu trabalho de pesquisador eu pude ir
entrando em contato com esse assunto de
diversas maneiras e fui me encantando
cada vez mais e fui conhecendo e vendo o
quanto que comer tem a ver com gente e
tem a ver com Colômbia
a discutir
EA E especialmente do ano passado para
cá quando a gente fez um projeto
maior de pesquisa sobre hábitos
alimentares
eu comecei a me interessar mais pelo
assunto e seguir estudando e seguir
pesquisando por isso eu vou contar um
pouquinho para vocês um pouco dos
achados desta pesquisa que que a gente
viu mas muito das minhas inquietações Ou
pelo menos uma grande inquietação a
respeito da nossa relação com comida
hoje
e a gente nesses estudo entre o ano
passado e esse ano falou com mais dentre
entrevistas em profundidade
entrevistas online com mais de 500
pessoas e o que mais de alguma forma
fala que o pesquisador tem que ser
neutro e a gente tenta né mas sempre o
que a gente ouve e fica na gente de
alguma forma é o que mais nos chamou
atenção e mais
nos despertou curiosidade foi entender
que comer tá ficando chato a gente
conversou com um monte de gente falou um
monte sobre comida e lá pelas tantas de
começou a perceber que comer tá ficando
difícil tá ficando complicado e como eu
falei eu gosto de comer aí gosto de
cozinhar escutar isso pensei meu Deus
como que comer uma coisa tão básica que
é que tá com a natureza que nos trazem
energia que é tão fundamental pode está
ficando tão chato
é o que eu quero é ir contando para
vocês um pouco dessa pesquisa e desse
processo para vocês acompanharem um
pouco das minhas inquietudes quando a
gente pergunta para as pessoas quais são
as primeiras associações o que que vem
na cabeça quando a gente fala o que que
é comida que que é comer vem um monte de
coisa legal tem um monte de coisa
interessante tem alegria em prazer de
energia vem felicidade para o
relaxamento diversão muitas coisas e
aqui nem estão todas as palavras que a
gente conseguiu captar porque comida é
muito mais do que um alimento uma
nutrição para o corpo é o que a gente já
tanto falou hoje aqui é nutrição para
alma para o espírito Oi e aí as pessoas
dizem é alimento para o corpo e para a
alma é sentir todos os sentidos ao mesmo
tempo é prazer
bom e é mais do que isso é um momento é
poder reunir as pessoas queridas é
juntar à mesa para gente conversar e a
comida ajuda a reunir mais de uma vez eu
escutei não sei pesquisa Mas na vida que
o melhor lugar da casa e a cozinha
porque na cozinha que as pessoas se
encontram é na cozinha que a gente se
reúne para fazer uma comidinha a gente
faz um grupo de pesquisa não pode faltar
um monte de coisa especialmente comida
porém comida faz com que dez pessoas que
estão aqui para conversar e que nunca se
viram na vida se conecta em e
rapidamente comecem a contar histórias
no comida tem tudo a ver com afeto e aí
como dizer ter entrevistado Domingo é
dia de reunir todo mundo da minha mãe
daí é uma massa um churrasco é uma festa
o ou seja comida é Pura Emoção E aí eu
acredito fala que a família tem Conexão
direta com a memória quase como
instantaneamente ela ativa o que a gente
sente o que a gente lembra tem uma frase
de Adélia Prado que ela fala que a
memória guarda aquele aquela aquilo que
ela ama eu acho que comida é um dos
grandes dispositivos de armazenamento do
Nosso Amor do nosso afeto
porque se a gente parar para pensar quem
nunca parou e tentou reproduzir ou de
alguma forma voltar aprovar o pudim da
infância o pudim da vó o pudim da mãe e
não conseguiu
Eu sempre peço e às vezes
e a
hoje faz exatamente a mesma receita Tal
Qual ficou no livrinho e não dá certo e
não dá certo não por um problema do
ingrediente não dá certo porque a gente
consegue repetir um monte de coisa mas a
gente não consegue repetir o afeto do
mesmo jeito e eu falo isso até por
experiência própria
eu herdei receita de uma coisa é
que tá acontecendo que tu só tem a
ganhar com a família que é um
prato de Natal
há algum tempo mas tenta da minha vó e
algum tempo eu comecei a fazer E aí
nunca dá certo não é que não deu certo
da mas ela mesmo diz que falta alguma
coisa e às vezes fica até melhor mas ela
não é o salgadinho da Julieta é o
salgadinho calor eu fico frustrada por
um lado mas por outro eu me dei conta
aqui o que eu não consigo e o elemento
que eu não tenho é reprodução poder
reproduzir o imaginário de comida que
tem ali na comida de vó e aí eu acho que
a receita a receita lá é replicável mas
o gosto do Amor
gosto do amor é impossível de ser
repicado são outros amores que se formam
como novas receitas Mas a gente não
consegue resgatar o gostinho da infância
do mesmo jeito da mesma forma
Oi e aí o que é bacana que quando a
gente pergunta para as pessoas Eu sempre
gosto de investigar O que que tem de
memória nos assuntos que a gente está
pesquisando que tem de lembrança e a
gente pergunta assim Quais são as
lembranças mais antigas envolvendo
comida e aí o que mais aparece é comida
de vó e carinho
e aqui tem umas verbalizações para
contar isso tô sim minhas avós faziam
coisas maravilhosas é lembrança de colo
de vó difícil dizer mas com certeza é
final de semana é férias na casa dos
avós os almoços gostosos e o lanche no
meio da tarde também não podia faltar
meus pais me dando almoço de aviãozinho
o comidas que formavam carinhas feitas
pela minha mãe quando eu era muito
pequena ou seja mundo de significado o
mundo de afeto que vai além da comida
que prato
Oi e aí eu acho que essa é a melhor
síntese e essa entrevistada ela falou
Falou depois ela parou pensou assim
comida boa mesmo sabe comida boa é da
minha avó e começou a rir e deu para ver
que aquela memória direto lá no passado
mas principalmente lá no coração
e aí
nessas nossas nossas amostras tinham
muitas mães e a gente pode ver que tem
uma relação direta entre comida e amor
de mãe pelo bem e pelo porque a
quantidade aliás tem gente que diz que
mãe é um ser ocupado por natureza né E a
comida e alimentação quase que é um
aditivo para essa culpa a quantidade de
mães que falava Ai meu Deus eu como eu
queria poder
almoçar junto com a minha filha todos os
dias como eu queria fazer uma coisa e
que eu não consigo como é que eu dou e
não conflito e é quase como se a forma
como a mãe alimenta o filho
certificasse num certo sentido tão bom é
a sua mãe E aí eu acho que essa tem uma
verbalização aqui que conta isso
direitinho passou um ano que eu me
aposentei fazer eu tô mais em casa agora
que eu estou sendo mais dona de casa
cozinhando sendo mãe eu acho que quando
essa entrevista entrevistada falou isso
ela nem se deu conta da intensidade
daqui porque ela tava me contando ela
nem percebeu o tamanho do depósito de
emoção que tinha nessa frase mas ela de
fato estava se sentindo muito mais mãe e
eu ficava na casa dela então eu
conseguia perceber isso depois que ela
ficou esse um ano fazendo café almoço
janta e sabendo o que que ela coloca na
mesa para filha dela e filha dela tem 12
anos
o e ou seja isso de certa forma
registrou uma nova fase da relação entre
mãe e filha e aí não só desse jeito mas
diversas outras expressões o que a gente
vê que esse assunto como alimentos meu
filho era um momento
difícil tenso das nossas conversas
porque comida Amor de Mãe como eu falei
o reforço da culpa não alimenta direito
não tô presente isso foto para chegar e
ficar pelo menos 15 minutos final os 15
minutos finais ali do almoço antes de ir
para escola e também porque eu não dou o
melhor exemplo como é que a gente dá uma
ele hora tempo tinha mãe que dizia como
é que eu faço meu filho comeu salada se
eu mesmo odeio salada como é que eu digo
pulando come menos porcaria se uma dor
chocolate e aí como é que esse conflito
faz o que eu me
certifique como uma boa mãe E aí a culpa
o potinho da culpa só aumenta
Oi e aí um outra forma de lidar com a
culpa é uma certa A negação da culpa e
mães mais jovens a gente viu quase que
uma atitude Rebelde assim porque elas
diziam Ah eu faço eu dou mesmo eu compro
comida congelada porque isso não vai
mais Afe vai ser um discurso e eu só
tava perguntando sobre hábitos
alimentares um discurso tão inflamado
que era certamente aí Lobo elaboração de
alguma coisa que tu não tava ficando
muito bem
organizado naquele momento continua
enrolado
E
aí elas dizem eu faço o que eu posso e
muitas vezes eu dou miojo mesmo fazer o
quê peço pizza fazer o quê É porque
também são mães que trabalham para
caramba cuida você também sozinhas e
ainda tem que ser
faço comida todo dia eu não tinha
coragem de dizer isso a elas
Oi
e aí o outro ponto importante era comida
como compensação reparação sabe o que
que é o trabalho a semana toda aí chega
final de semana eu consigo que meu filho
vai comigo no supermercado fui eu dizer
que não para o monte de coisa eu tenho
como ir junto e divertido e é legal e é
um momento que a gente tem para estar
junto como é que eu vou lidar com isso
eu sei que não é melhor coisa mas eu
acabo fazendo
essas questões todas elas estão lá na
nossa geladeira na nossa despensa nossas
panelas e isso interfere muito na forma
como a gente vai se relacionando com as
pessoas com a comida e com a vida
o e compensação Vamos combinar que uma
coisa que acontece com as mães não né
porque quem nunca é que eu tô vendo um
monte de mulheres
por alguma razão comeu muito muito mais
chocolate do que devia Quem nunca por
alguma razão depois de um dia super
estressante diz quer saber eu essa e
comeu
se alguém não sofre desse mal e
é porque eu sou
e aqui então disse eu tô tensa eu
preciso comer se eu como eu fico feliz e
eu tenho a comida como uma coisa meio de
recompensa sabe e que eu gosto claro que
nem todas as entrevistas a gente tinha
essa oportunidade mas as presenciais é
porque isso vem quase como um tão de
confissão assim eu posso é mesmo a
recompensa que eu mereço mesmo então já
me ferro semana toda
Oi e aí o uma outra se quiser eu acho
que é um presidente que a gente se dá o
vamos sair para jantar por exemplo é
mais para compensar as coisas que tu
abra a mão no dia a dia e tem muita
coisa que a gente abre mão no dia a dia
não dá cada vez mais a gente se impõe
mais coisas cada vez pratinhos para se
equilibrar E aí como é que eu faço como
é que eu escolho chama Ops eu fico muito
tempo não existe é caso infelizmente a
realidade é essa a gente tem que tem que
mudar mas hoje a realidade e aí como faz
e aí a gente está falando de alimentos e
comida uma coisa que tem tanta
importância e cada vez menos tempo e
menos dedicação a trouxe um dado aqui de
uma pesquisa do IBGE que embora não seja
super atual acho que as coisas não
mudaram e eu até tenho medo de atualizar
porque eles compararam o ONU
que horas investidas em preparo de
comida com o percentual de mulheres
economicamente ativas lá em 7123 por dia
das mulheres trabalhavam e dedicava duas
horas ao preparo das refeições
88 por cento as refeições eram feitas em
casa eram feitas em casa e só 11 fora de
casa em 2011 e 44 por cento das mulheres
trabalhando boa parte das que eu
entrevistei 15 minutos é o tempo de
preparo de uma refeição
e talvez deixando tudo congelado de um
pouco mais de tempo mas eu não sei nem
se ela tinha um tempo para fazer o
feijão para congelar e sessenta e nove
porcento das refeições redação em casa
mas já diminuiu e trinta por cento fora
casa ou seja
e não tá fácil e aí é nessa hora quando
a gente começa a entender e falar de
rotina que a gente começa a ver tem
culpa tem frustração tem cobrança tem
pressão EA coisa vai ficando mais
complicado
preparar as refeições escolha alimentos
que constituem um processo de relação
com a comida que estão com a comida
estamos perdendo Principalmente nos
grandes centros urbanos
eu e nessa a gente vai ter um conflito
gigantes entre o real eo ideal todo
mundo tem algum ideal ou alguma coisa na
memória memória que pode ser verdadeira
ou não que condiz com o processo que é
bem diferente do que a gente tá
conseguindo praticar E aí quando a gente
pergunta como seria a refeição ideal vem
comida é saborosa e sem culpa e mulher
às vezes não sei culpa que não engorde
e também compartilhada com carinho e sem
pressa e foi uma surpresa porque a gente
fazer essa pergunta assim como ser
refeição ideal e o início achava que ia
ser assim de equilibrada prato colorido
aquelas coisas que a gente escuta e veio
muito mais sobre o momento e sobre o que
tá em conjunto com a comida do que
comida em si
eu creio que alguma coisa feita com amor
um ambiente agradável cercado por gente
querida o Real o Real já mais complicado
a gente até acompanhou alguns momentos e
outro tive que tomar café com gente que
foi assim cinco minutos e fui saindo
conversando com a pessoa na no corredor
e tem gente que me disse depende do dia
tem dias que não consigo nem sentar e
tem uma outra atualização pela tanto
assim ah não moço eu não tenho da fôrma
seu como o jantar também não mandei o
quando ela tem fome
é tão e tudo isso ainda calibrado com
uma ambição comum a todas as pessoas que
ser saudável eu diria que a gente tem
vários modelos na
padrões para gente respeitar padrão de
beleza padrão de felicidade sucesso
profissional um monte de coisas e agora
aparece essas criando um padrão de
saudabilidade também E aí todo mundo
disse que de alguma forma eu percebi
passou pelos traços muito mais aquário
do que dos números mas que tá tentando
ser saudável de algum jeito e a gente
ouvia nas entrevistas expressões o que
mais tinha era Tô tentando tô buscando
procuro
dia de semana eu tento final de semana e
fio pé na jaca todo mundo tá tentando de
alguma forma algum tipo de Equilíbrio e
a gente perguntou Existe algum alimento
que você tem evitado comer 82 dois pelas
pessoas que eram sim e Existe algum
alimento que Você incorporou setenta por
cento desse sim Eu só coloquei essas
duas
de verbalizações aqui que embora não vai
falar muito sobre elas elas são bem
emblemática quer porque e o que saladas
porque estou gorda e saladas folhosas
Porque meu namorado brigou
hoje eu vou falar mais sobre isso
e não é o paradoxo da boa alimentação
que é uma necessidade e uma dificuldade
então gente sabe que a gente tá muito
longe de fazer o que tem que ser feito
mas como é que a gente faz como é que a
gente concilia consegui ser saudável
para mim é muito difícil porque a comida
às vezes é uma compensação de algo que
não aconteceu como eu queria ou ainda
lazer e é muito chato ficar se polindo
quando você tá no momento de lazer e aí
a gente perguntou o seguinte para você
se preocupar com alimentação é
veio fundamental para de fazer em chato
Mal Necessário estressante e não só
porque eu tenho que abrir mão de um
monte de coisa porque eu não sei o que
fazer entendeu porque a gente tem hoje
cada vez mais e mais e mais informação e
o que é pior as informações mudam as
informações são contraditórias o que é
bom hoje é ruim amanhã e o que que eu
faço e aí a gente tenta modismos que
podem ter fundamento Total ou não Oi e
aí antes o ovo era veneno agora a gente
tem que comer um ovo por dia
uns manda não comecar outros dizem que
faz falta e tem essa coisa também da
lactose e aí como é que faz
E sem contar que a gente ainda precisa
ficar um pouco para nós mesmos cioso
para nós porque a gente não sabe mais o
que tem dentro das caixinhas E aí nossas
impressionante como as pessoas falam não
sei não confio não sei de onde vem e me
assusto Então acho que estamos em um
momento de desconfiado as marcas
e a tem uma nutricionista que fala ela
até numa Ted Talk fala sobre isso que a
sua fique fala a gente tá vivendo
nutricionismo que se assemelha ao
terrorismo ou se tem coisa demais para a
gente dá conta e nesse momento será que
dentro tantos padrões que a gente criou
a gente não tá alimentando um padrão
inatingível de saudabilidade será que
não dá para ir aos pouquinhos a gente
vai aprendendo e vai assimilando
com isso tudo é quase como se o prato
fosse ficando vazio não fazer o alimento
mas vazio de significado vai se
esvaziando e a gente vai comendo
rapidinho qualquer jeito ou não sei se
os que eu tô comendo faz bem ou se eu
como bem e fico feliz fumar culpa e aí
culpa intoxica eu não sei mas eu acho
que culpa também deve deve entupir As
veias do coração
bom e quando a gente olha passado versus
presentes Olha só antes quando a gente
perguntou o que mais a memória que tinha
a memória afetiva e um monte de coisa
legal a gente pergunta qual a sua mais
recente lembrança envolvendo comida é a
pizza pronta que eu comi ontem à noite
estou de dieta eu ver o almoço sem
gracinha todo perdido o controle comida
um bolo de chocolate inteiro e aí eu
perdi tá frase que fala meu almoço sem
gracinha e assim uma coisa tão básica
tão bonita tão legal tem tantos
significados
vendo vai perdendo e perdendo a força e
vai deixando de ser legal e vai perdendo
a magia e vai desconectando da memória e
o amor coitado do amor que a gente
falava com que tem a ver com comida O
amor é um ingrediente que dificilmente
a
p**** ressaltado uma panela onde tem
muita pressão muita atenção muita culpa
e muito medo amor precisa de espaço
então não dá para cozinhar com amor com
tanto medo
Oi e aí eu encerro a minha fala fazer o
que significa a minha inquietude com a
pelo que é por favor nós vamos deixar
algo tão lindo cheio de significados se
tornem mais uma atribuição chata da vida
eu não tô dizendo que a gente tem que
chutar o balde fazer de tudo pelo
contrário Mas é isso da maneira mais
leve vamos parar de nos cobrar vamos e
vamos viver a vida mais natural como
faziam os nossos avós isso obrigado
E aí